new years in Nepal a time for
celebration and for piety Hinduism is
the main religion here and at this time
of year the devout fill the streets
where they asked for good fortune in the
new year and the men endure elaborate
tests of strength and endurance but the
village of bow day demonstrates its
religious devotion unlike any other
there just one man will stand before the
gods and undergo a painful trial his
name is Krishna Chandra and with
thousands watching he will allow a spike
to be born into his tongue if his tongue
does not bleed it is believed that gods
will grant his village prosperity in the
year ahead in Nepal the new year starts
in April when fields have just been
planted and people are praying for a
good harvest in BO day that prayer comes
in the form of a sacrifice according to
legend the village of bow day began its
unusual ceremony four centuries ago to
mark the end of a very dark time a
forest demon had been terrorizing the
town when the villagers finally caught
him they paraded him through the streets
his tongue silenced by a metal spike
ever since bow day has celebrated the
new year by reenacting the demons fall
its tongue piercing day Krishna has not
eaten in three days part of the
preparation for his ordeal on his way to
the ceremony
Krishna stops to pray at every shrine
and temple everywhere the gods have
visited in the square the crowd begins
to buzz with anticipation as boh days
mayor takes the stage
once on the platform krishna is greeted
as if he himself were divine the blade
has not been sterilized
there's no anesthetic the priest
Babu Kashi just dabs Krishna's tongue
with oil to lubricate
[Music]
[Applause]
his tongue does not bleed for the 11th
year in a row krishna has passed the
most crucial test but his ordeal has
only just begun
now he must carry a heavy bamboo icon a
symbol of the god Shiva through bow days
cobbled streets Krishna ends his walk at
the town's main temple just as he
crosses the threshold
Babu Kashi removes the spike from his
tongue as a lasting testament to
Krishna's and the town's piety the spike
is nailed to the temple wall Krishna is
free to head home to break his fast and
for the priests bubble Kashi and the
rest of the villagers this painful
ritual has once again served its purpose